au québec on le sait il ya moins de
monde dans les églises
combien ont été transformés fermer
carrément détruites
on a vérifié
[Musique]
depuis 2011 le québec perd en moyenne 40
bâtiments à vocation religieuse
chaque année
[Musique]
si on recule d'à peine 14 ans le québec
comptait 2751 lieux de culte aujourd'hui
il y en a 500 de moins et plusieurs ont
changé de vocation
[Musique]
l'église sainte germaine cousin à
montréal a été transformé en garderie et
en logements communautaires l'église
notre dame de fatima à saguenay qui
avait la forme d'un tipi a été démolie
l'hiver dernier pour faire place à des
condos et l'église saint thomas à
pierreville dans le centre du québec
aurait eu besoin d'importantes
rénovations
mais faute d'argent elle a été démolie
[Musique]
le gouvernement du québec finance la
restauration du patrimoine religieux
mais depuis 2013 les montants sont moins
importants on dit souvent que montréal
c'est la ville aux cent clochers
la particularité de la métropole c'est
que plusieurs églises qui étaient
catholiques ont été vendus à d'autres
religions
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose suivez nous
[Musique]